Democrats holding climate change rallies
today like this one where New York Mayor
Bill DeBlasio was heckled inside front
tower meanwhile Bill Nye the Science Guy
taking a shot at Republicans for not
supporting the green New Deal what I'm
saying is the planets on fire there are
a lot of things we could do to put it
out are any of them free no of course
not nothing's free you idiots grow the
up you're not children anymore I didn't
mind explaining photosynthesis to you
when you were 12 but you're adults now
and this is an actual crisis got it
safety glasses on Wow he wouldn't be
joking like that the whole global
warming hysteria is the perfect
encapsulation of the Democratic Party
because I was this picture of you with
the fire extinguisher on you it's both
nerve centers in the party there there's
psychological problems and their policy
priorities because one it makes them
feel superior to other people it makes
them feel like they're saving the world
even though they're really not and it
also makes them feel like they're in
touch with nature even though they're
the ones that live in the cities and
it's the Conservatives doing the hunting
and the fishing and the agriculture in
rural America in terms of policy they
just make people feel guilty and use
fear in order to do what they need to do
because if you think about it all of
their solutions to everything is the
same global warming hysteria is just the
Trojan horse to get in to all the things
they want to do regulations tax hikes
ridiculous amounts of spending and
attack being oil and gas companies
because this is all about feeling guilty
for the success of capitalism they can't
control capitalism and that drives them
crazy so the green New Deal just gives
them the opportunity to control
capitalism well thank you for your
welcome we rest might love hearing from
Richie Rich and the plutocrats on this
show Lisa
when you see something like Bill Nye go
wild like that or you hear about all
these rallies today they had a big one
in Washington Howard University
it makes me think oh the Democrats see
political advantage in talking about the
green New Deal climate change in the
light Republicans don't see an advantage
you just heard from Jesse but they don't
have any plan what are you making them
well I would say Democrats are dumb if
that's the assumption that they're
making because if you look at something
like the green New Deal it's gonna be
detrimental in states like the Rust Belt
States I would say for Republicans the
irony of this is if you look at part of
the reason why we've been leading the
world and reducing carbon emissions is
because of innovations and things like
natural gas via the private sector yet
what Democrats want to do is move us
entirely off of fossil fuels which mind
you it makes up you know over 80% of the
United States energy consumption but
pertaining to the rest both states like
have fun going out to you know Michigan
Wisconsin and talking about how you're
essentially going to gut jobs there jack
up energy prices which mind you
disproportionately impacts lower-income
Americans so much so while you've got
union groups like the FL
CIO putting out statements condemning
the green New Deal talking about the
fact that it's a threat to jobs a threat
to families in the way they live their
life so you know what if Democrats think
this is a good idea like be my guest
have fun with it
all right so let's take a look at this
remember when Alexandria Ocasio Cortez
said this how many years until the world
ended we have 12 years left to cut
emissions by at least 50%
if not more you may laugh but your
grandkids will not the congressman now
saying those comments were quote dry
humor she says she's she was being
sarcastic Dana well it's funny actually
so they always say that about President
Trump as well right so they always say
oh he'll say that the president was like
oh that obviously was a joke and they
make fun of him for so I actually think
wasn't it in the green New Deal
documents that the reviews on our
website that it was 12 years so haha
hilarious I do the green New Deal rally
I think that's pretty interesting I
don't understand the day or the
significance of course like we could use
all global warming kidding I know you
guys hate that when we all say that but
I do think that's pretty interesting I
sent an article to Gregg yesterday
because I couldn't believe it on the
same weekend that they're doing green
New Deal stuff in Illinois they're
planning to introduce a bill into the
state legislature to tax people that
bought an electric vehicle $1,000 apiece
per year guess why because they're not
buying gas so that means that they're
not paying into the gas tax but they're
still on the roads so it's really like
an anti carbon tax that is why the
circular argument gets frustrating for
conservatives and guess what we also
have jay Inslee another Democratic
candidate Greg he's out on a motor
scooter and saying you know this could
be the future you have Joe Biden saying
there are ways that you can look at this
that won't a lien eight anybody because
we rejoin the Paris deal there's ensley
on his scooter and you know that there's
a middle ground for conservatives and
there is a huge middle ground and we're
in it right now you see people from the
Sierra Club you see Bill Gates they're
right there it's called nuclear power
it's the cleanest safest more
environmentally for most environmentally
friendly type of energy that we have
right now and whether you like it or not
that's going to solve climate change I
want to make two points so a couple of
things bugged me about you know what
nuclear energy has a bad rap because
it's always been associated to the bomb
right you knew the nuclear bomb and yeah
renewables well the accidents are few in
the end they'll solution I mean a good
yeah they're but the research shows
anyway renewable energy somehow immune
to a serious environmental reporting
when was the last time anybody read an
article about solar power waste ok solar
panels create a ton of waste by 2050
there's gonna be like 78 million metric
tons and this stuff is difficult to
recycle and contains toxic chemicals
like cadmium which can leach out into
the soil in the water
William cadmium cadmium so what I'm
saying is no one talks about this but
this is gonna blow your mind do you
remember when there would be an oil
spill and they would show the little
ducks and everybody felt bad they were
cleaning the little ducks have you ever
seen any footage
from any photographers on the millions
and millions of large and rare birds
that have been murdered by wind farms
wind farms are now the leading probably
one of the leading predators of birds
second to cats
I believe murderers okay so where is
PETA where's PETA where's the Audubon
Society where all the green groups where
the bird watchers because are they all
bought for and paid for by PETA I don't
know or by the green groups the point is
we used to see these oil spills we don't
see the dead birds that tells you
something about the media we don't know
what's this where's the justice for the
birds no the facts actually no it's a
great point it's actually millions of
the migratory bird treaty act companies
that if you are responding you can get
responsible for it you actually are
fined
yes so they they blame the companies but
nobody talks about the and there's so
much roast chicken of this you don't
care about the birds watch great for you
one you're gonna get the letter D is for
dealing with climate change with BS yeah
yeah that's what you gave us